foreign
group shocked Wall Street when its chief
executive qsong Lee abruptly resigned in
August throwing the leadership of one of
the world's largest private Equity
groups into disarray Lee was negotiating
a new five-year pay package worth 300
million dollars in stock the Ft reported
talks on the contract broke down after
the firm's strong second quarter results
in July leading to Lee's surprise exit
which was announced by Carlisle on a
Sunday evening ultimately the issue was
not pay but instead control
Carlisle's three billionaire co-founders
David Rubinstein William Conway and
Daniel daniello have stepped aside in
2017 naming Lee and Glenn yonkin as
co-chief Executives in 2020 Lee won a
power battle that left him in charge but
made him enemies internally say insiders
Junkin left to enter politics and is now
the governor of Virginia
get Carlisle's three co-founders retain
board seats and collectively controlled
the company they grew increasingly
concerned about the pace of change
inside the group Carlisle established
its dominance in corporate buyouts in
the 1990s and 2000s by forging political
connections from offices in Washington
D.C it was once nicknamed the
ex-presidents club because it
encountered George H.W bush and John
Major as advisors but it had been
overtaken over the past decade by more
aggressive New York Rivals such as
Blackstone from New York offices Lee had
been working to catch Carlisle up
expanding rapidly in credit real estate
and insurance-based Investments he hired
new top Executives and Consolidated the
group's once unwieldy operations Lee was
looking for Independence in addition to
a large potential windfall in continuing
to set Carlisle's path but he overplayed
his hand he wanted complete autonomy
said one person close to the situation
the founders gave it to him then they
took it away Carlisle's Old Guard is now
back in power co-founder Conway has
become interim chief executive as the
firm searches for a new leader
[Music]